sans plus
onze ans
quarante ans après avoir réalisé
ensemble 200 nua leurs embouts retrouve
en écoutant les bandes originales à la
logique qu est ce qui vous vient à
l'esprit
je laisse ma pensée c'est un courrier
d'excusés
dans une démarche d'un homme d'écriture
parce que du sang noir là ça fait du
bien illusion bien là c'est la moitié
des chansons pour amar les guitares des
pays d'en haut
tout ce qui est là pour me faire voyons
premièrement tout ça sur le même album
pop et
[Musique]
qui est un monstre qui caractérise toute
cette période y en nous cette opération
là c'est le mot liberté liberté faire
des choses liberté d'avoir cette
ouverture il avait intégré tous les
musiques que chaque musée peut
s'exprimer
[Musique]
oh
vois que tu verras
il y avait ceux telle complicité
d'hommes bien aussi à ajaccio nouveau
l'anecdote de doni farmer qui inquiète
bâtard et on joue et on finit la chanson
un peu d'idées ça fait du bien de ses
fils et deux nuits de suite que ça finit
pas lente qui continue à jouer un
immense sur la batterie puis j'ai tout
le monde se greffe à ce que ça continue
dénichez québec rock ouï 1978 tandis que
lens a pas toujours été facile c'est
vrai débat qui était difficile parce que
je dis et serge était quand même avec du
monde avec qui a travaillé depuis
longtemps et puis moi quelques occasions
je me sentais un peu déstabilisé ils
vous disent de moi y était déjà
mais y'a rien dramatique
ces deux mondes
wire drame à partir le soc tardy qui
était répandu une rumeur muscle c'est
normal qu'à travail de l'enregistrement
il ya une seule chose qui se pose puis
de l'inconfort et justement il ya eu des
rumeurs à l'effet que des années après
la parution de 200 nuits à l'heure où
vous n'êtes pas parler c'est vrai ça
leur nom est aidé en avait des chemins
différents mais jose ont continué
d'amitié tu as toujours là on a continué
à faire des arts martiaux en sont les
arts martiaux à la 84ème si on fait un
gros pour faisait une sorte de l'aïkido
je ne savais pas sortir sergerie un mois
pourquoi ça de gagné elle s'exprime
vous avez gagné plusieurs félix lors du
tout premier gala de l'adisq avec 200
nuits à la mi mai par ce que
nous suivons des gens qui nous appellent
tu racontes de la suite les rhinos fait
que moucheté de giverny albert a fait
carrière depuis richard et ailleurs ce
sont là les dansant dans son écriture
personnelle pour ses albums
c'est vraiment transition une croisée
des chemins
puis il ya but physiquement pour moi
c'est un poids sur le contenu à queue
mais je sais ce que je mange art est
intéressé il faut pas une affaire du
week-end et spectacle avec marc lanne
les saisies c'était pas dans l'oubli
non on avait compris
k
[Musique]
maty
jeudi ce cabinet j'ai la cassette je
dise que compact j'ai le téléchargement
alors pourquoi devrais acheter le 40e
anniversaire le moment le remastering
fait quand même une expérience une bonne
différence parce que il ya quelque chose
dans l'enregistrement que qu'on a le
goût de m quand on n'a plus de moyens
aujourd'hui pour aller les fréquences à
les derniers sont classés déchausse
accès à ça aide beaucoup ça donne une
rondeur à l'album que comme mon cheval
blanc attend
[Musique]
merci le collectionneur de musique qui
vous parle semble-t-il que dans le
sous-sol de recherche il y aurait des
démos de nos semblables
ça vous tente pas de ressortir oui la
pandémie d'archivés j'ai beaucoup à ça
puis c'est faut faire le ménage comme
angers cas moi j'ai un atelier grave eux
j'ai mon studio maison et puget j'ai
tout vu des cassettes j'ai des vidéos
depuis la guerre je développe c'était
papiers volés l'autre arrive avec son
lot
[Rires]
[Musique]